[Music]  Ben Affleck and Charlie Hunnam shirtless  on the beach if the actors were  photographed in Hawaii on Thursday while  training for their new Netflix action  thriller triple frontier with Garrett  Hedlund and Oscar Isaac Charlie showed  off his toned bod in red swim trunks  after he was seen goofing off and  wrestling in the water with co-star  Garrett you owe it to yourself in July  2017 Ben actually dropped out of the  project to focus on his health and  family but seems he had a change of  heart  as the 45 year old actor and his tattoos  were on full display while rocking navy  blue swim trunks for the training with  the Hawaiian lifeguards should be a lot  of fun  [Music]  [Applause]